kind of a dark question but you think
we're headed towards a war with china
the united states versus china
i hope not
i hope not in the cyber space and
potentially even a hot war i think
there's too many people with too much
money to be lost to go to a hot war on
both sides but
eventually we're just gonna someone's
gonna have to stand up i mean the
subjugation of hong kong and the
genocide of the uyghurs and the
colonization of tibet i mean taiwan is
the next big thing i mean xi jinping has
made it very clear you know xinjiang
tibet hong kong
taiwan so
we're gonna have to stand up for taiwan
for for different reasons both for moral
reasons but also for semiconductor
reasons we need tsmc to be on our side
we cannot have china take over tsmc
so um there's different reasons why
we're going to have to protect taiwan um
and you just hope it's not a hot war i
mean at this point
well but also from inside the
governments of china and russia as well
but china i guess is is the powerhouse
here is how do how do these governments
get reformed is it is there hope for
them to become democracies like true
democracies
of representative democracies and sort
of
reform them
to be um
to be
ethical players on the world stage no
empire lasts forever and it's impossible
to predict when these regimes fall i
mean no one no one thought the soviet
union was going to fall when it fell
like that like if you study like the
news and the scholarship of the era
no one knew that the tunisian government
was going to fall after muhammad bozizi
laid himself on fire no one no one
really no one predicted that that would
become what we now know as the arab
spring right these things are impossible
to predict
and one day the chinese regime will fall
i just
we don't know when um yes
you know but and there's quite a few
folks who talk about the fall of the
american empire
and it also concerns me that we don't
know when that might fall you assume me
as a very excited naive american i'm
very excited by this project that i
think is the beacon of hope in the world
still
but uh
that's probably how you you know
uh that's how that's probably how you
feel before it's the end it's a yeah the
party you want to leave the party before
it starts to deteriorate um
i i think america could continue to have
like a major major leadership role for a
long long time
i think certain things we do will become
maybe no longer possible in terms of the
way we intimidate people on the world
stage and the term especially the way we
use our currency as a weapon
i think that that's going to decline
over time as we become more of a
multi-polar world
but i do still believe in america and
the values that were founded on despite
all the warts i do believe in us and i
would prefer us absolutely to be the
most prominent of the multi-polar world
vis-a-vis a regime like russia or china
absolutely
you